hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for tonight again we
have a few quick updates one about a
fortnight coming to the iOS and Android
systems as well as a quick dev update
that they just released about an hour
ago so let's get started so first up in
the dev update they talked about the
jetpack obviously if you guys have
played for tonight you know that the
jetpack was supposed to release but then
got delayed for the hunting rifle
apparently according to the devs there
was some internal testing they did and
something [ __ ] up and they didn't want
to release it broken
so they're gonna wait a couple weeks to
basically fix it up more they're still
going to be releasing new items whatever
that happens to be in the meantime so
we're still getting new content of
course and then next up they talked
about the teams of 20 update if you
haven't already played it it's basically
five teams of 20 they battle out like a
normal mode of 100 people just more five
teams of twenty team with the remaining
players wins super quick there's a lot
more air drops and there's a lot more
treasure it's a lot of fun in it believe
it dropped yesterday so if you haven't
played it definitely go check that out
and then they talked about a few little
teases for the version 3.3 patch notes
and in that they're going to be getting
or adding supply lama's basically
they're going to be just like treasure
chests or ammo crates but they're going
to have a few bits of interesting gear
inside so the devs told us to definitely
tell us what we found in there I'm going
to be speculating that that's going to
be some high tear drops because there's
no point adding a different type of
chests if we're already getting that and
ammo we're obviously getting ammo in it
maybe it'll only be shields we would
only be something specific I personally
think that it's going to be a high rank
beer also because it that is in the save
the world mode the PvE mode of
four-night and that is like their kind
of like their microtransaction version
of that game so I'm assuming like I said
high tier high tier ranks of weapons are
going to be in there where they're going
to be I have no clue but that seems
really nice that they're going to be
adding that we'll have to see how that
plays out next up is that they're going
to be getting rid of smoke grenades the
apparently the dev said that not many
people use smoke grenades and if they do
it's not in the correct way that I guess
they're supposed to be used and so
they're going to be tweaking those a
little bit they're gonna put them back
in the vault take them out for a couple
weeks and then hopefully fix those ups
that that's more useful and then like I
said we talked about fortnight battle
royale coming to mobile basically the
dev said it's going to be the same 100
player game that everybody knows on PC
Xbox
one that playstation4 all that stuff
except it's going to be on our phones
and tablets it's going to be fully
supported by epic so it's not one of
those cheap knockoffs to get some free
money from another developer it's
basically there's going to be starting
Monday you could sign up for the event
the invite event on iOS with Android
coming in the next few months and
they're also going to be introducing a
cross player cross progression for
PlayStation PC Mac and iOS and
eventually Android like I said in the
coming months this means players across
devices can squat up with friends and
play together so I don't really know how
that's going to work
meaning that you might have a few
friends playing PC but then you're
sitting there on your phone playing I
don't know how that's going to be much
of an advantage or that or it's just how
they're going to do it in general I
don't know but this looks really cool to
me I want to know what you guys think
about this but like I said starting
Monday March 12th you can sign up at
fortnight comm for the invite on iOS
email of invites will start rolling out
thereafter when you're invited you'll
receive an email with the link to
download the game from the App Store if
you don't see if it right away don't
worry we'll be adding more players
regularly over the coming months players
to receive invites from epic we also get
friend invite codes to share with other
people so that we can get more people in
on the action to participate though
you're going to be needing an internet
connection with at least iOS 11 on at
least an iPhone 6s or 6s II iPad 4 mini
iPad pro iPad air 2 and iPad 2017
devices sadly I'll not be able to
participate I have an iPhone 5 but not
like I was going to be playing the iOS
version of this anyway but if you happen
to be wanting to play the iOS 4 tonight
just for some fun maybe you're a school
during your break or you're on the
bathroom like most of us are gonna be
doing on our phones
play quick round two for tonight and
you'll be done and over with I'll leave
a link to this article from their
website in the description if you do
want to check that out just in case you
are semi interested and then that's
going to be the end of the video today
guys hope you guys did enjoy I'm really
excited about this for tonight iOS thing
even though I'm not going to be playing
it I think that it's a decent move and
it's kind of weird how we've never we've
never seen big companies and big games
do stuff like that on the phone before
like you've never really seen a Call of
Duty game from the call of duty like
companies make one for iOS for tonight
and epic games are starting to push that
initiative now which is really
interesting like I said like the video
if you guys did enjoy it really does
help me out subscribe if you're new and
covering a lot more
for tonight news guides tips all that
stuff to make everyone a better player
in the coming weeks when all that stuff
when other stuff gets released any new
items any of that stuff I'll be covering
all of that when that happens to release
my two most recent videos are gonna be
Alan scream for fortnight we talked
about the bullseye icon and the treasure
map icon are the locations if you guys
still need those it's gonna be the other
that one video and then the other video
is going to be about new leaked skins
that are possibly coming in the near
future for four minutes so I definitely
want to check that out if you guys
haven't seen those already hope you have
a great rest your day MP cell boys